let's talk about some more media lies
and family and all that stuff we got the
story from politico
americans split over florida's
controversial bills on gender identity
and race so controversial let me just
slow down here and correct the article
before we get into it they're of course
referring to the parental rights and
education bill which the democrats call
don't say gay which is a lie it's weird
it is uh controversial fine i guess but
it is not a bill on gender identity and
race that seems strange to me the bulk
of the bill in florida as we often
clarify is parents have a right to know
what's happening yep that and no sex sad
for preschoolers to third grade five six
seven eight years old that's it teachers
are still allowed to talk to kids and
say the word gay to their faces a
teacher can still go up to a child and
say you should be gay that is not being
banned in any way
makes you wonder what republicans are
actually doing bill doesn't even nearly
go far enough
so here we go i love this politico says
the poll asked respondents about
florida's parental rights and education
dubbed the don't say gay bill by
opponents now here's the funny thing in
their actual poll the question refers to
it as don't say gay
and i'm like that is not proper polling
dishonest but you're still seeing the
majority
say they agree with it i really don't
like how they're framing it as americans
being sharply divided on this issue i
mean there's a 16 point gap there and
you've got 30 you this is an issue where
33
of democrats
support what desantis did yeah that's
not sharply divided i'm sorry like when
you're over 50 and your opponents are at
35 imagine if donald trump had beaten
joe biden by you know 51 to 35
that's a landslide right like so it's
just the whole thing is skewed the
questions are skewed um but they had to
at least admit it that they were that
they're not
one of the crazy things is that uh
69 of americans support the banning of
sputnik and rt it appears
i mean that's kind of crazy to me
you should just
watch that stuff knowing it's probably
bunk but see what they're telling people
for sure but i'm gonna try i'm gonna see
if i can find the uh the exact exact
question here because it's funny the
political poll question is not just a
here we go instead of saying
uh do you support
the parental rights and education bill
out of florida they say this
as you may know the florida legislature
has passed a bill labeled by opponents
as the don't say gay bill limiting the
teaching of sexual orientation and
gender identity to florida school
students some say that limiting these
discussions will protect children from
inappropriate classroom topics while
others say it will block important
conversations about lgbtq issues to what
extent do you support or oppose the
following items in the bill banning the
teaching of sexual orientation and
gender and identity from kindergarten
through third grade
strong support is 37 percent somewhat
support is 13 and then somewhat opposes
11 strongly opposed 23. we're to clearly
see the majority there is in favor of uh
in in support of it they then go on to
ask the basic basically the same
question and then say limiting lessons
on orientation and identity after third
grade to age appropriate discussions and
you still have the majority 32 percent
in support of 20 somewhat supporting so
you still have the majority there being
like yeah it should be age appropriate
my question is what would the percentage
have been
if they didn't frame this
in favor of lies from the democrats on
the left they tell you
what the opponents of the bill call it
but not the actual name right in the
question how much bias can you get with
it and they push the lie from the
democrats instead of telling you what
the bill actually does they say
opponents say
it will block important conversations
about lgbtq issues that's irrelevant
what if they said this let me read you
the question reframed as you may know
the florida legislature has passed a
bill labeled by opponents as the don't
say straight bill limiting the teaching
of orientation and identity to florida
school students some say that limiting
these discussions will protect children
from inappropriate classroom topics
while others say it will block important
conversations about traditional marriage
issues to what extent do you support or
oppose the following items in the bill
there's no difference in the bill
i could literally call it don't say
straight and say republicans have just
banned teaching children about
traditional marriage that's true
literally true but see politico comes
out and they polled people now here's
here's why i bring this up
even though they falsely framed the
story based on lies
the majority still agree with it exactly
it's weird there's like a super majority
of americans and i know this is this is
pretty radical like that the vast
majority of americans
they don't want to sexualize kids like
they want to let them be kids you know
like why do we have to make everything
sexual not every someone tweeted at me
today they said not everything has to be
gay
and i think that that's right like yeah
great you do you live your life fine
but not everything has to be about you i
remember back um
there was a there was a cartoon
made by this uh uh this guy he was on
reddit i can't remember his name he
deleted it it was about atheism i read
it read it when it first started one of
the default subreddits getting a ton of
attention was
r
atheism that meant if you were a random
regular person who went to reddit you
would see posts from people about being
atheist
so he made this cartoon where he
basically mocked the idea because
reddit propped up a community that was
just ragging on people for what they
believed and it's like why
you know why is that a thing why is that
the default position why
you know
i kind of forgot where i was going with
that but ultimately what ends up
happening is
the dude deleted the cartoon and you
can't find it anywhere anymore i mean
maybe it's been archived somewhere but
it was actually i thought it was a great
point because
the cartoon ends by saying like why is
this a default subreddit to just
you know be on everyone's feed
yeah like why just just you know be mean
to people all the time why just prop
that up
i lost my train of thought with with my
point so you guys just start talking
well the the big thing here is like
this stuff really is happening across
the country like we did this uh video uh
last week uh showing like say basically
saying thank you to governor desantis
for protecting our kids from women like
this in our kids public schools and it's
this woman who started this sexy summer
camp and she's talking about um
she's talking about how she's like i
encourage every kid kids of all ages all
ages to you know basically abuse
themselves and she starts talking about
how her nephews who started abusing
themselves when they were toddlers like
what going into this and it's like guys
this is happening like there's a co-work
a coordinated effort to sexualize your
kids and like break them and so thank
god you know i remember my point now
basically i brought that up because what
the community was doing was it making it
was making a whole bunch of people who
didn't know a whole lot about religion
just blindly be
part of this hate mob against
christianity but nothing else
and so when when you look at what's
what's happening after the don't say gay
or whatever there's like a tick-tock
video where a guy is like wearing a
shirt with pride flags on it and it's
like
why why do that
what do you think is happening they
don't look at the news they don't read
the bill they have no idea this is so
it's not just about the atheism
community on on reddit or anything like
that it's about the fact that there is
some truth to out of sight well out of
sight out of mind is literally true
if you can control what people see from
the bulk of their social media you are
controlling what they will complain
about so what do we get on twitter
people are talking about covet and then
one day like a switch was flicked it's
ukraine
because they want to make sure the only
thing you see is this these stories of
this information this is why the
democrats called it don't say gay they
want to make the argument yeah and then
even ben shapiro walks into that trip
ben shapiro tweeted to ted lou this bill
stops you from indoctrinating kids with
your weird gender ideology or whatever
something that affects and i'm like no
it doesn't it literally does not do that
the democrats made up a lie they claimed
here's the framing of the bill
conservatives walked into it and said
well actually that framing of the bill
is a good thing and it's like both of
you are talking about something totally
irrelevant to what's going on
but this is this is the game
media will often frame things i'll i'll
put it this way as well i'll say this
politico doing a poll where they give
you a paragraph breaking down an issue
is a total violation of polling ethics
in my opinion they should say this
how do you feel about the parental
rights and education bill out of florida
strongly support somewhat support
somewhat oppose some would oppose don't
know or no opinion and guess what would
happen don't know would be 80 exactly
and hey that would be funny wouldn't it
yep instead the funny thing is they
still try and frame it in favor of the
left's argument and the majority of
people actually still support the bill
yep it's really it's got to be
depressing for them because they have no
i mean think about all the levers of
cultural influence that the left has
here right like they've got the
mainstream media they've got hollywood
they've got the music industry corporate
america big tech like everything like
they control so many sources of
information and they still can't win on
something like this
well i think maybe their power is
faltering
you know
less and less people are interested in
the lies the lies have become more and
more obvious i think of it like they say
that wealth lasts three generations
someone works really really hard and
builds a big business becomes a
billionaire right their son and or
daughter inherits it and then takes the
company over and maintains it they have
kids
no so what happens is
you know the the child of the
entrepreneur was still taught the values
of hard work but not you know was was
not someone who founded a company and
could maintain that then they have kids
who are taught to a certain degree the
value of hard work but certainly not how
to start a company or even to maintain
it so by the third generation you see
wealth start to fizzle out well i think
of it uh similarly in terms to how the
democrats have institutional control and
how the media is playing
it seems like
you know a couple two generations ago
media was strongly controlled by savvy
marketers who were like keen and
manipulating
then their kids inherit it and they're
like keep the system up keep it rolling
you know cnn or whatever
now we're on the third third generation
who are just like i have no idea what's
going on and so they try doing the most
outrageous and garbage propaganda that
doesn't work and we're waking up to it
yeah well it's interesting because one
theme that has repeatedly come up as
we've discussed the quote unquote don't
say gay bill is that if you're going to
refer to it as an anti-grooming bill it
does which would be great it doesn't go
nearly far enough and the left hears
that young children below a certain age
are not going to be discussing sexuality
in the classroom when it would be wildly
inappropriate and they go oh my goodness
but what about gay people how are we
going to protect them instead of saying
look this is a bill that is specifically
set up to protect children from
inappropriate discussions and also to
ensure that parents are notified by
certain things that the school district
might otherwise try to keep from them
even though they have a right to know as
parents and all the left can think about
is what about protecting the poor sweet
gays that's literally it and and and
that's why i think it's better to call
it the don't say straight bill
and and i am outraged
these republicans are banning
discussions on traditional marriage
i i agree with the democrats we should
come together and say we should be
allowed to teach kids about traditional
marriage we should that should actually
be the standard right like i mean this
is this is the truth this is what you
should be shooting for um i still have
no problem with being like we're not
going to talk to preschoolers or third
graders about you know about sexuality
well yeah this is the bizarre thing
right imagine thinking you're going to
get public opinion on your side
trying to fight a bill that says you
can't talk to children
below a certain age about sexuality with
but then
gay people won't be able to tell
children about their sexuality when
they're in preschool who like what world
do they live in that they think the
average person is going to hear that and
go oh no oh my goodness sheamus
according to this poll at least we have
around 34 percent of people who don't
like that
so you've got a third it's true if you
were to extrapolate the data
who are hearing this from politico
probably for the first time and saying
four-year-olds should be taught these
things
you know i thank goodness that i don't
know anyone who would be in support of
that personally i mean maybe i do know
some people who are lefties who i made
friends with when i was younger who if
yeah but about this and reconnected
might say that supported but they're
zombies yeah exactly those are
conversations with that's disgusting i
have a lot of friends from back during
occupy i have a lot of you know that i
talked to and they
don't know what's in the bill that's
what i'm saying yeah this is dangerous
you know how do you how do you defeat uh
you we have a poli we have political
zombification in this country we have a
horde tens of millions of political
zombies and they are tearing away at our
system
no no that's that's right but here's
where here's where donald trump was a
huge benefit to the movement is that he
showed us basically how to fight back
and that you could actually call out the
bs and the lies and end up winning these
political battles and now you're seeing
that being transferred to desantis and
desantis is calling it out that press
conference he had was really beautiful
and i know you know another example of
this and he's not the greatest example
but is greg abbott with what he did with
that executive order now agree or
disagree on on what he should have done
with that executive order uh the one
declaring gender modifications for
minors to be child abuse right so
there are some disagreements on that but
guess what he trolled the entire
national news media into saying
and letting americans know that this is
happening yeah gender modifications for
children are happening and by the way
republicans think it's child abuse
something that like 80 percent of
americans actually agree on we polled on
this um and even like 60 percent of
democrats want to ban this stuff from us
absolutely yeah i mean i i think the
issue with the debt with with your
average democrat who votes democrats
they don't know anything about what's
going on exactly yeah so how you you
know we've got this battle
i think one of the core elements of the
culture war is people who are discerning
who watch the news and seek out true
information and try and fact check and
you have people who don't
the people who don't are being you know
hypnotized i'm just imagining there's
brian stelter and he's got his you know
watch going left and right don't watch
fox news only we can give you the true
good information and i think it was jake
tapper who said you can't read wikileaks
emails only only we can do that was that
tabernacle no cuomo cuomo was that was
cool i'm pretty sure it was
no i think it was tapper sure maybe
either one of them whatever cuomo's gone
but you have regular people who uh
until you sit down and talk with them
you know like i've told before i have
friends who say they'll talk to their
parents like hey watch tim's show and
hear what he has to say and they're like
ah i don't want to watch that conspiracy
stuff and they're like he's reading
cnn.com like he's reading politico polls
they're just giving their thoughts on
this and like a critical assessment and
then i actually end up sitting down with
my friend and they ask questions they're
like nah trump did this and i'm like oh
actually xyz and then they're like well
i didn't hear that i'll pull it up and
show them like one of my favorite
stories when i was talking about china
stealing the dna from people that's
terrifying it was it was an npr story
that china was getting access to
people's dna through covet testing and
there are people who didn't believe me
and they were like that's conspiracy
mumbo jumbo and i'm like npr right here
like i i if you don't believe it and i
got no problem i don't trust npr half
the time either
but what is it do you trust npr or not
well but that's the kind of thing that
npr would be incentivized against
reporting on which makes me more likely
to trust them about it because their
general interest is in promoting
information that makes all of the kova
testing and vaccines etc sound better
rather than worse so if they're willing
to say that it's probably because they
have something
yeah i also think that common sense
should take a play right like there's
there's this over expertization
thing too as well like we have to like
read these things and it doesn't matter
if it's fox news npr cnn msnbc
you if you have a little bit of common
sense you can sniff out bs right like it
does i don't care what degree you have
or you know if you have a phd or
whatever but we are battling against the
bill burrs and the ethan kleins you know
bill burr who went on joe rogan and said
look joe i just turn on the tv
every two weeks
and do what they tell me to do and it's
just like
if they told you to walk off a cliff
would you do it like you have you have a
limit you have a red line right you get
ethan klein who's like you even got to
think about it man you just go to cdc
and you just tell you what to do and
it's just like
yo throughout history governments have
oppressed people how could you be a
supporter of resistance if you're
telling people to just blindly walk in
lockstep with the government's mandates
that's what we're battling against
there's like a complacency and a
laziness like people don't want to deal
with um
really bad things right like we we end
up like there's like a psychosis around
that like when things are really bad we
don't want to pay attention we just it's
a human thing and that's why it always
had there's a cycle to it well i i'm
curious what would the nra for families
have to say about this and try to do
about these problems about all so
basically we where we're coming at it is
like start with the basics right like we
we wanted to get politicians comfortable
talking about the transgender issue like
the left wants to put gender identity to
civil rights law
that has major consequences men and
women sports men and women's private
spaces men and women's prisons like
men and women's uh you know uh homeless
shelters like there's a lot of really
bad things here and so we started with
the sports because that was what
politicians wanted to talk about but
in reality
americans are broken sexually like we
have disconnected sex from family we've
disconnected it from children it's now
just totally hedonistic and you're a
weirdo if you have six kids right like
have you seen the meme where it's like
it's like you know i think it's like
nine kids lined up and then the mom's
pregnant and then there's like a bunch
of leftists saying like this is
disgusting like that well it's so i mean
but that just
shows their misanthropic hand they hate
human life ultimately they really do
they'll never acknowledge it what they
love is pleasure and engaging in
pleasure and they see other human beings
existence is very inconvenient to them
because that requires that they set
themselves aside and make choices that
are for the benefit of others what's the
article it's like in order for there to
be a feminist utopia the family must be
destroyed or something like that yeah no
that was part of the marxist movement
it's true yep yeah well because you need
to you know people uh this is
interesting back during occupy wall
street
there were uh two different govern
governance governments i don't know what
you'd want to call it there was the
general assembly which was everyone
gathered around and then the
facilitators effectively controlled what
could be said by who and when and how
money was spent but then you had a group
of people who tried creating what's
called the general union
and these guys explained it to me that
the way the union would work is that
every tent at occupy was a family that
knew each other's interests desires and
needs
and so a representative from each family
would discuss with the larger group
instead of a group of random people all
adhering to perhaps you know the
authority who facilitate the meetings i
thought it was interesting that their
approach from it was we're a family
we have needs amongst each other we'll
convey those needs to other families and
then ultimately see how that greatly you
know but that was crushed the general
unit was was basically wiped out of the
park they were ostracized they were
smeared and lied about it's like they
reinvented the wheel yeah right like how
society works like it is organized by
families i think we've gone
the reality is and sheamus you were
talking about this earlier like we went
decades without a like robust lobbying
uh special interest group in dc
representing families like who makes
politicians pay a price when they were
voting to trans our kids or voting to
allow pornography unrestricted you know
no age verification
they just they they say these things
don't happen and right the problem is
once and it's good that they do
but so yeah in the long run i think you
know we're starting to see that the
narratives start cracking people start
realizing what's going on with their
kids one of the one of the things i
think is really important not west
virginia that's happening people think
they can move to west virginia which is
the second most trump supporting state
in the country after i think it was
wyoming they think they're going to go
there and find a red school that's going
to be like
middle of the road look we're not here
to teach your kids to be religious we're
just going to you know teach your kids
let them be kids play baseball and
they'll learn math and then it turns out
that these woke activists are still
running for school board in red areas on
purpose they have a mission they have a
cause they found their purpose
so you you get these kids
who are going to grade school in west
virginia and they are surrounded by all
of the cult woke-ism
they have all of these books like
whiteness contracts and stuff like that
and ebermex candy and then when you
point it out they call you a liar and
say you're making up and the media
protects them thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm we'll see you all there
you